[Music]
[Applause]
he's a hall of famer he is the voice of
sunday night football he was on the call
for the ravens and the chiefs and this
sunday night he's got packers at the
niners along with chris collinsworth and
michelle tafoya he's al michaels back on
the program al how you feeling today
i'm feeling pretty good dad for a guy
who just basically got up as you know
it's a
22 out here something like that yeah i'm
not ready for my close-up but most of
the audience is radio correct we're like
like by a 10 to 1 ratio would you say
yeah good yeah and by the way you're
you're a hall of famer too or wait a
minute or you just won that i saw you
won the award
you did a podcast but you were saying
you were not happy about getting the
award because it meant you were closer
to
the finish in the beginning yeah did i
hear that correctly yeah why i mean dan
you got to enjoy every moment i know but
i'm so competitive al that when i got
the call i thought okay
you're going to go in the hall of fame
i thought they were calling to say you
won sportscaster of the year not you're
going into the hall of fame so they like
you know how this is it's a young man's
game and you're you're you're trying to
you know you're trying to fend guys off
and do this
you're you're talking about the the
group in north carolina yeah that was
correct okay
remember this i think i got into that
hall of fame in 1997.
okay yeah 24 years later yeah daniel you
got a long long run ahead of you okay
now this is this is therapy okay okay
because i know you probably don't go to
really intensive therapy yeah so you
listen to me uncle big al okay and uh
and just hang with me baby just eat meat
and potatoes
no vegetables and stop worrying about
all this other stuff stop worrying about
it you have a long way to go okay but do
you worry about your future
well
at this point
when they talk about long-term investing
and you know i love the market i talk
about like thursday thursday's long-term
investing for me right now
uh
no it's a little it's a little different
you know i used to sit there and think
oh you know
let me do the math and all of a sudden
i'm at this point in my life
i can't do that anymore i'm just i'm
having too much fun number one and doing
these games is still great uh you know
we're off and running we did the dallas
tampa bay which was great you know you
feel really energized after that and the
other game you know the the sunday night
game baltimore and kansas city is one of
the all-time classics as far as i'm
concerned uh so you know what i just
kind of go back enjoy it enjoy the
moment to look forward to next week and
not think too far down the line
best decision you ever made career-wise
was what
um interesting cool um
well i got very lucky early on i would
say
you know started minor league baseball
in hawaii got the cincinnati reds jobs
that was a decision made for me by them
uh
left cincinnati to go to san francisco
for triple the salary you know i left
the big red machine to go to a moribund
franchise but that turned out to be a
pretty good decision because that opened
the way for me to do
monday night baseball on abc the reds
would not have let me do
any games beside their games but the
giants said you can do network
television
so that was a pretty good decision
because that opened that opened the door
for abc
which turned out to be 30 years and i'd
say the other good decision was when the
20-year monday night football ended for
me in 2005 i had to make a choice to
stay at espn to do it kind of their way
in a way
have john madden leave me
and we'd worked together for four years
and fred gidelli and jurassic producer
and director who are still with me after
all these years that was a hard decision
but you know it was hard for me to kind
of make that move and that's where
oswald the rabbit came in and all that
other stuff that we that junk we threw
into the the equation
uh so i would say you know there there
have been three or four
joints a lot of
junctures along the way
where i had to make a choice and it
turned out to be pretty good
what do you think about the future of
like peyton and eli calling a game of
are is that going to catch on with other
other networks i think to a degree but
dan i think when people want to watch a
game
uh i think they really they're kind of
into the game itself
and i think peyton and eli are two
fantastic guys i watched some of it
in the in the in their first outing it
was fun they bring guests in it's
different it's um
you know somebody said it's a gimmick i
said it's a little bit more than a
gimmick it's a different way maybe to
watch a game but if the game is really
compelling and you really want to watch
the game
you know i want to know the guys are
there i want to know certain stories
peyton and eli and their guests can
bring you a certain vantage point uh but
i think if you really get them i mean if
you're watching baltimore in kansas city
the other night and there's a secondary
telecast i think it can t it can
distract you from what's really
happening in the game
you know you can still be a part of
what's taking place but you're doing
other things and and you're not
those guys are not physically together
uh they're not in the stadium so it's it
was it's kind of fun i you know i
enjoyed listening to them for a while
but you know i went back to the
conventional telecast most of the game
how would you work with peyton as far as
doing play-by-play and and then his
ability to break down again i know you
work with chris and i but sure i don't
know if it how different would it be
with a quarterback in there as opposed
to chris collinsworth no he'd be he'd be
great uh because he's great at whatever
he does and in fact at one point it
looked like you know he might want to
get into the more conventional analyst
role somewhere
and and may at some point um
i worked with the quarterback dan phelps
for a couple years now we had dennis
miller in that mix as well so there was
a whole
different animal uh but i think
peyton is so smart he's so sharp he's so
talented in so many ways
that you know he he would adjust to it
and i think the thing with peyton is
that he would um he'd immerse himself in
it the one thing peyton
does is he doesn't do anything
half-assedly he is a hundred percent in
periods uh he wants to make it work you
know i did part i did one of those
peyton places with him he came out to la
and we talked about monday night
football the years on monday night put
the yellow jackets on had some fun with
it uh he's terrific i think when
when the time comes if he doesn't wind
up in an ownership situation which could
happen uh he'll be great
well i i often tell people when they
talk about tony romo and how good he is
i said
nance has the hard job because you got
to sort of grab whatever you can grab
when you can grab it from romo because
romo is a jockey on a wild horse and jim
nance kind of has to grab it and then
kind of plug it back into the game
is that a fair assessment
i was a jockey on dennis miller's wild
voice i know what that means
but i believe it was the wildest moment
though with dennis miller where you go
oh wow
well yeah
well he he would come out with some
lines that were just i mean it would
just blow me away and i'd start laughing
hysterically and and that's sort of a
disjointed thing for the audience
because you know you get the crowd noise
and and people were talking we had a
three-man booth the greatest line that
we ever had
the miracle of the meadowlands game in
2000 when miami had a 23-point lead
fourth quarter against the jets jets tie
the game with potesta verdi
miami goes down the field they scored to
take the lead in the final minute
testimony leads the the jets back down
the field
to tie the game and sends it into
overtime so and remember they tied the
game with just a few seconds left in the
game
michael was something like tessa already
backed the pass
he hits jumbo elliott in the end zone
the the tackle eligible jumbo elliott
for the touchdown it's the first
touchdown of his career he's been in the
league like 11 years it's the first
catch of his career dennis matter of
factly says couldn't keep him down
forever
so
dennis had some fantastic lines he was a
lot of fun to work with it was it was
different dennis was a guy who some
people saw this is great it's different
you know he's he's he's kind of like
he's as don olmeyer who hired him said
he provided an element of danger
and i think that an audience likes an
element of danger and i think when you
look at like charles barkley in a way
and you know charles has been there for
so many years and there's so many it's
it's it's tremendous it's uh
it's a treat but there's an element you
don't know where he's going to go people
didn't know what where dennis was going
to go but uh you know it lasted two
years then we had the chance to get john
madden and uh and the way we went he's
all michael's uh he's got the packers at
the niners sunday night on nbc along
with chris collinsworth michelle tafoya
do people imitate you too you
it's
it's hard i guess because i i really
don't have it's not like imitating
cosell or
or chris berman or somebody you know who
who really has a very distinct uh
delivery
uh mine is more
i guess you know down the middle
to a degree the one thing i mean i get
all the time is you know the phrase i
used 41 years ago uh they still they
they still shout that back at me but
that's fun yeah and we've talked about
that in the past i mean the fact that
that um
it brought so much joy to so many people
and and it's still still joyous and even
if they weren't born they've heard the
story they watch the movie they
understand what happened so that's kind
of a fun thing it's better than you know
playing back something where you really
screwed up the call and they're playing
that back at you that's for sure i uh i
have one of the danettes seton and uh he
does and now michael's impersonation oh
oh oh oh yeah
let me hear it let me hear it okay here
we go well it's very specific to one
game because i noticed uh when watching
ravens chiefs that you seem to genuinely
enjoy watching lamar jackson run the
ball
and so there would be scenarios where
you would say like uh ravens five wide
empty backfield for jackson he snaps a
bullet there he goes
is that
really is that me
there he goes and there you go take off
running down the field
that's not bad you know
that's not gonna go right i i better go
uh ratchet that down a little bit
i don't know
hey give me seton give me comments for
it you know as long as you're doing me
give me chris what do you think now see
look look at what this guy just did
that's what i love about football right
there i mean look at this catch
[Laughter]
give me what about romo oh can you do
that
give me one romo
jim jim i think they're going to run it
jim i think they're going to run
pretty good
give me get me out wait give me al as
his impersonation one more time
jackson under center drops backwards
[Laughter]
are you going to drop that from your
repertoire on sunday night now
you screwed me up
i knew that way aaron jones maybe yeah
49ers 49ers don't have any running backs
left so i can't see you know one and
garoppolo doesn't run so it's got to be
already
if trey lance gets in
oh now we're talking yeah
very interesting give give al what al is
going to sound like on sunday night when
trey lance gets in there
empty backfield five wide
lance drop there he goes
beautiful wearing your head or in your
head al i'm sorry totally yeah totally
it's crazy
you started letting all that stuff get
into your head you're screwed i'm
telling you
oh man hey i got i gotta have so i gotta
have selective amnesia right now thanks
shane really appreciate this uh great
great to see you and uh have fun on
sunday night thank you buddy
hey enjoy the ride don't be thinking
about it don't be stan come on love you
you do a fantastic job you're at the top
of your game you got 25 more years okay
i'm telling you right now
i don't want 25 more years all right you
get 20 you get you get 23. there we go
mary goes
thank you bud
thank you thank you that's uh hall of
famer
michael's packers niners if he drops
that on sunday oh
oh
that's gonna be great career highlight
oh that'd be great